and thank you for joining us at 11 on
this friday night i'm brian loftis i'm
denise valdez las vegas restaurant week
is just a few days away and it's really
a great opportunity for businesses to
give back this year's event is
especially important as restaurants
bounce back from the pandemic sacha
loftis joins us live tonight with more
sasha
[Music]
denise and brian this is really a great
fun way to give back to those in need
but business owners tell me it's also a
great opportunity to showcase everything
they have to offer as they continue to
rebound
nick palmeri is something of a staple in
the local restaurant business every day
i like your challenge he owns kaitano's
ristorante in henderson and says he and
his staff have been hard at work getting
ready for las vegas restaurant week it's
a great effort
for
us to
generate revenue
and donate money the annual 12-day event
which kicks off monday gives some of the
city's finest locations the opportunity
to help people in need
each offers a fixed price menu and gives
a portion of the proceeds to three
square food bank i think it's
great that people are finally you know
going out full capacity and it's also
great for restaurants like this as they
embrace pre-pandemic employment levels
the bureau of labor statistics says 390
000 jobs were added to the u.s economy
in may brian gordon principal at applied
analysis says hospitality rebounds are a
big part of that we've seen the evan
flow in the restaurant business as well
and now we're starting to see them get
back to where they work so if you're
hoping to try something new
it's a perfect time to do just that
while also helping those who need it
most it is a great opportunity for
people to venture out
now las vegas restaurant week starts
this coming monday the 6th and continues
through the 17th a lot of other
restaurants in addition to gaitanos are
also participating we have a list and a
link on our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now